all I can say is this the easiest way to
avoid running with the cops is not to
have a run-in with the cops
meaning that meaning that as a general
rule you know the the the virtually
every immigrant community the United
States will take as an example virtually
every immigrant community to the United
States originally had lots of problems
with the cops the Jewish community early
in the 20th century had a lot of
problems with the cops in New York the
Italian community had lots of problems
with the cops the Irish community the
German community the Hispanic community
virtually all of them when they came to
the United States had significant
community had significant problems with
the cops as crime rates declined in
those communities it turns out that the
problems with the cops tend to disappear
and so the easiest way to get rid of a
lot of these problems is not to put all
the onus on the cops but to say okay the
cops are human they're gonna make some
bad mistakes and we need to prosecute
them if they do something really
terrible obviously but if you really
want to tackle this thing on a systemic
level crime rates have to go down